i want to start with you
what was the most important goal for you
in coming into this role
i really um was totally enthralled by it
it was it was all kind of
a beautiful universe created by david we
kind of i was just a coggin
really there's so much i mean first and
foremost just getting to work with david
um i'm such a fan of his work and how he
explores time
in his movies and they kind of have this
beautiful kind of
trance like you know quality to them uh
his films and uh he kind of um is quite
a chameleon in that sense as a filmmaker
and
the script totally had me thralled i
read it and i
could see so many parallels to you know
a young actor's journey you know in
trying to be successful in hollywood or
whatever and
you know how sometimes you know that
blinding
you know reach for ambition can be
detrimental to yourself to your close
relationships
you know at what cost uh do you want to
be this thing or
you know in this case he wants to be a
knight or have his legend you know on
on the lips of everyone in in the
kingdom um and
yeah it just was a really beautiful
script and then all these guys joel
alicia um it was a wonderful cast that
david assembled so i was just
excited to be a part of it and you
[Music]
gawain
with you joel you have a very
interesting connection to this film
already as you've played this character
before
what types of conversations did you two
have about the character and kind of the
different interpretations
i had zero input into
uh or influence over uh the character of
garn i mean
you know when i played garland it was in
a very commercial
action-driven film and this is a
completely different story with a
completely different tone
and aesthetic and a journey to it that
is so unorthodox
and unpredictable so i mean
apart from the name of the character
i felt like these two things exist if
they're books they exist in
very different parts of the library if
that makes any sense
for sure but how like i don't know
serendipitous is that
yeah well you know when you get old
enough things come around again you know
it definitely but but maybe it says a
lot too actually to
to to not be so uh
facetious it's like you know what what
really
lures different actors to different
things and definitely something that
piques my interest uh apart from the
creative team involved
in this was also you know getting you
know
get on the horse and you you've got a
crossbow and you know
part of what i carry around with me
through all my choices or often
what i carry around me is is i identify
with myself as a 10 year old boy
um and and that 10 year old boy has a
little hand on my back it's like yeah
yeah yeah go on
do that again because i would have loved
to have been a part of something like
this when i was a boy
well you're you're talking about things
coming back around so i have to ask you
i interviewed you for
the gift dope movie in 2015. um
and i asked you like oh i'm a big star
wars fan would you ever reprise the role
of owen lars and i feel like it was
pretty like far-fetched at the time
to ask but now did you ever think this
would actually happen
oh you know i i have faith in things i
always
figured like it you know it may come
around if it came around then great if
it didn't come around
then then star wars still exists in its
old forms
yeah no but i mean it's amazing isn't it
world continues to prove itself to be
such a fan favorite and that means that
we get to go around again what has it
been like stepping back into the star
wars universe
all of this stuff could get me killed
you know all this right
talking about any of this stuff could
get me killed and then i won't get to
step back in
um i'm i think it's everybody's well
aware that i'm
i'm about to put my foot back in that
universe and it's um
i'm just yet to film anything of myself
yeah that's so exciting i don't want to
get joel edgerton killed personally so
that would be bad well i mentioned that
the imagery in this film is just
immaculate from like the portraits to
the crowns and the costumes i kind of
feel like
like normally that's kind of a basic did
you take anything from set but i feel
like
any time david said cut i'd be like can
i keep this
did you guys keep anything they've took
the talking fox home
i want a talking podcast that is
um the costumes are beautiful and i
remember one of the first chats i had
with david he sent me this book it was
like
two over 200 pages of malgosh's costume
references and it was like you know
scales of fish and all sorts of things
and you know the kind of intricacy that
goes into these costumes
uh you i kind of felt like tilda swinton
at cans or something you know
i love that picture
i love it uh so did you keep anything
did you get to take anything like
i would keep the portraits to be honest
hey you gotta you got on that portrait
oh my god
david gave me a little swatch of my um
uh on my cloak you know he has this kind
of like beautiful like mustard
i don't know golden cloak thing which
was really beautiful
so he gave me a bit of that which was
cool i have that at home these stories
were kind of
i would say like the original cinematic
universe dev i'm sure you get asked a
lot like when is death patel gonna do a
superhero movie i really want you to i
fan cast you as nightwing in my head all
the time
are you interested in that yeah i mean i
never
i i never even imagined myself in a
world like that i kind of
operate from a lot more low self esteem
to imagine myself
you know in spandex superhero um
but that's very sweet of you
[Music]
are you ready
[Music]